all right
let's [ __ ] go i'm just like gonna go
to like admin
hey kraken hey craig hey craig hey hey
am i gonna die in here this is like one
of the dumbest things i've ever done
like none of what i just did was smart
not even really sure why i did it you
know that was not
like self-preservation just [ __ ] out
the window on that one man damn
all right guys we'll hang out oh oop
hello god damn folly's dead body up in
the top of the cafeteria
well that's gonna happen here the
toughest ride it's him
it does eliminate him that's true that's
yeah we don't have to worry about farley
we don't worry about it uh yeah i walk
from admin from that one
when i were both in admin and then it
was just i just walked up as just as the
doors closed and yeah
i can clear well i can't clear alana
because she found it but i clear bruce
because i
followed him from admin down to
electrical fix the lights and then back
so he can't have done it well cricket
was following me the entire time of
being super sus
but he didn't kill me so there's that
hmm
uh okay okay i mean it was weird you
were you're being weird you weren't
doing any tasks that's right i
literally was i did all the tests yeah
i'm pretty sure that chrysler did the
admin
right now i didn't do any tests i didn't
do any tasks then why were you just
standing in advent alone
because why didn't you do any tossing
because i was trying not to get
to not get killed by criken over and
over and over
i'll skip did anybody else see anybody
up north
anybody else hop right here i was in
electrical
when the body was called they were like
it was me yeah i was
that was it was afraid top half
electrical yeah yeah
well okay
i'm gonna be real mad i'm really
confused i was trying to clear bruce and
now he's throwing suss on me and i'm not
no i i genuinely think you guys are okay
i think you guys are okay it's super
it's super weird like you can focus
on everybody i don't i
i don't think it was you i'm telling you
i don't think it's you
okay well again i just told you you were
weird but i'm not saying it's cracking
i'm saying i'm weird it's really mean it
is
you're weird you're not weird kraken all
right i won't i'll avoid you i guess
i don't know man we're all gamers we're
pretty weird just in general yeah gamers
are like really unique
so like it's like a really uncommon
breed
like nobody games
anyway fredo sauce bye
[Laughter]
i love it i really don't think it's
bruce or kraken i i i don't
i think that banter was them [ __ ]
themselves and the imposters silently
watching and enjoying i think is what
happened there
um which is why everyone but those two
was so quiet it's because it's so easy
to just observe
i don't uh i don't think it's them
could be kraken i guess i i know bruce
better but i don't think it was bruce i
think bruce was just getting caught up
uh okay navigation let's go
i would really like to not die
that would be great boom
doing tasks doing tasks
getting my job done tasking around
okay uh
we gotta go [ __ ] storage bruff
hey addiction hey hey hey hey
oh that [ __ ] standoff was beautiful
okay
hey bud
why did cracking leave did you just
leave even though the o2 is right there
dude
all right okay okay so i saw dave right
on top of it i knew it wasn't bruce oh
okay wait was this an opening maybe
maybe criken killed him to you know
silence him forever
what i okay he was going to figure at
you and all of a sudden he's dead
no okay listen i i was with you diction
okay you saw me i went through storage
uh south up into navigation
and then i see k-town and dave standing
over the body just waiting there
and then they reported as soon as i
walked around the corner can i ask why
you left admin the minute that the admin
o2 thing started going off
you were like i'm a piece and not do
that the admin o2
thing yeah we were an admin you and i
were doing a task i assume on the wall
and then you just [ __ ] walked out
when the
the a lot went off you just pieced i
guess i didn't notice that i don't
really do most of the emergencies i'll
be honest
i just do all the uh other deaths i i
will
i will say that i was with cricket for a
good bit of this last round
we didn't kill each other and i did see
him run up and i also did very much see
dave right over the body
the communications where i was hiding to
do the
emergency and then around the corner
uh i went to click on the emergency
thing
and then someone behind me had killed
bruce
and i was trying to click on the
emergency and then i came
out of it because fredo got it and it's
dave it's there
to report i'm 100 sure it's either
crycon or kerry because they were both
okay all right if it's not david's
kraken right
i mean no carry or crying it is not
kraken
i also like actually trust crack in here
you've done tossed right next to me too
he was looking at both of them staring
at the body yeah
i feel pretty good about that
still another one [ __ ] left though
okay
i i feel like kraken's behavior has just
not been
suss you know like oh mate crikey boy
has been doing things that make sense
that's all i'm saying
i'm gonna do this quick no wrong one
idiot done
okay everybody please leave me alone so
i can just stay alive it takes up so
much of the [ __ ] screen
you know oh my gosh i'm so close i'm
just i'm just
we're just almost done okay all right
okay
i'm getting there
come on come on come on i just
um i still ain't seeing [ __ ] though
i would like it if a murderer would oh
run it away run it away run it away run
it away run it away
what are you doing kraken you suck [ __ ]
he's not even i keep blaming him even
though he hasn't done anything wrong
okay great
that does that clear addiction it was
cracking
because now i'm scared of seeing two
people run next to each other because
that [ __ ] me before
you know oh that's convenient
just got locked in another room i love
that for me
all right i have one more task in
security but
oh oh my god
oh my god oh my god jesus
uh i was with
i don't know which one of you it is you
were with diction and now you're not but
i don't know where fredo
freda where were you just now alana my
path was on the right side
and it wasn't nav was cracking with you
the entire time i was
you just got locked in another room but
you just got i don't know which one of
you it is oh my [ __ ] god
what were you just doing this round
together right we did the reactor
together
big bring the [ __ ] out of this right now
i'm not i'm really not
i said the reaction together at the
beginning of this round round one
we were doing tasks together as well
you're right you're right and i have not
seen fredo [ __ ] at all said it was
with you
i have not seen enough i've not seen
alfredo we did just get broken up
and i thought dictionary was on the
other side i ran over to do reactively
reactor was already done
a door closed in front of me alana and
you popped through it to the other side
that's
the only time i didn't see you and then
diction was dead
i mean yeah but i didn't see him on my
side either i don't know where he went
look
i fredo i i feel like i had just seen
diction and what makes
what what what no what makes frank and
suss is being an addiction but what
makes fredo suss is the fact that i've
seen kraken do tasks around me multiple
times and i ain't seen
fredo at all and there's just dead
bodies lining up around me
i mean i get that i wasn't anywhere near
you i was like completely i want to pass
over and now
this round and last round
is just spinning a web of lies right now
that's not true i'm putting alfredo
i gotta i'm gonna vote cricket the
situation i have been with you this
whole round there cannot be this many
bodies
if it was me i think i have to go i
think i have to because i haven't seen
you i ain't the crack of
the addiction that i don't know what to
do no no no no no no
[Music]
no i think i have to i'm sorry freda
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
come on please please please
[Music]
please please kraken please stand and
[ __ ] send me daddy
yes thank you oh my god
empathy panic for alana right now
i was just like freaking out
someone from like falling off a cliff i
felt like i was about to murder one of
my kids i don't even have kids
oh thank god oh my god both hands over
lava and had to pick one of us to drop
because greg and you did get locked
where i had just seen diction but then i
was positive you'd be doing tasks near
me so i was like i don't i can't account
for fredo at all
[ __ ] i waited to see if there was any
benefit of the doubt and then i tried to
pick away at that when uh when i got
caught on that kill
i was like my one mission is to throw
all suspicion off of you